su reacción no se hizo esperar el frente
de salvación nacional principal
coalición de la oposición tunecina
denunció las detenciones por parte del
gobierno del presidente
este recurso a la represión no ayudará
al gobierno solo a grabar al deterioro
de la situación política en el país
estás detenciones se llevan a cabo según
procedimientos violentos e ilegales
porque se hacen solo sobre la base de
una decisión judicial en la legislación
tunecina se requiere una orden especial
para su ejecución
desde el sábado diez personalidades de
los medios políticos y mediáticos han
sido detenidas entre ellas el líder del
partido y clavó conservador en nada el
director de mosaic FM una de las
emisoras de radio más escuchadas del
país el abogado y activista político
por muchos tunecinos como un símbolo de
la corrupción
que tienen en común es que todo se
oponen al presidente pero el jefe de
estado refuta la tesis de una cacería de
brujas para él lo que está en peligro es
la seguridad nacional
vivimos una fase delicada y peligrosa y
los cargos contra los detenidos están
relacionados con un complot contra la
seguridad interior y exterior del Estado
respetamos los procedimientos y los
derechos humanos y este caso no tiene
absolutamente nada que ver con los
derechos y las libertades desde hace
varios meses el país sufre una
devastadora crisis económica y una grave
escasez de alimentos algunos creen que
el gobierno intenta desviar la atención
pública de la inflación que supera el
10%, esta medida se produce mientras el
presidente tunecino sigue construyendo
un sistema
hiperpresidencialista el alto
comisionado de la ONU para los Derechos
Humanos denunció el empeoramiento de la
represión desde que el presidente asumió
los planes poderes en julio de 2021 uno
de los principales dirigentes del
sindicato tunecino promete una nueva
serie de movilizaciones a lo largo de
febrero